gilles william goldnadel bonsoir êtes
avocat international président d'avocats
sans frontières vice président de
l'association france israël est votre
dernier livre publié le nouveau
bréviaire de la haine antisémitisme et
antisionisme
c'était chez ramsay
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
alors ce extraordinaire de vous avoir en
face tous les deux parce que vous vous
dites que les médias français sont tenus
par les pro sionistes et leurs modèles
souvent que vous exprimez vous dites
qu'en fait les médias français pro
palestinien
oui mais enfin je ne demande pas de
déshabiller les médias français alors
que monsieur en face de moi a indiqué
qu'il voulait des sionisés la presse
française c'est tout de même un peu une
nuance importante il me semble je peux
vous répondre là dessus mais vous avez
beaucoup parlé vous avez beaucoup parlé
vous êtes beaucoup parlé vous ne
m'empêchait pas de parler et me blanc je
veux d'abord wenger parce que monsieur
réalisé dans la défense de la violence
de la haine c'est que vous allez
m'empêcher de parler et m'a sûrement
parce que vous pensez un seul instant
que vous allez m'empêcher de parler
franchement je n'ai même pas envie de
vous parler alors c'est simple
jean prat on vous a raconté des
histoires tout de suite et vous dites
que j'ai écrit le nouveau pavillon de la
haine donc je sais un peu de quoi je
parle effectivement et c'est la boucle
nord ce que c'est vous êtes l'avocat de
la haine vous savez oui donc lorsqu'on
vous dit que on ne sait pas où se trouve
la haine moi je vais vous dire où se
trouve la haine d'abord monsieur
mathlouthi voir conte des histoires
lorsqu'il dit qu'il n'a pas mise en
cause très gravement l'existence même de
l'état d'israël en voulant sa
destruction le 9 juin
2002 monsieur mathlouthi indique radio
méditerranée parce que monsieur
mathlouthi veulent vendre de la limonade
ça me dérange pas du tout là où je veux
mettre en perspective sa vente de colas
c'est lorsqu'il exploite une radio qui
s'appelle radio méditerranée
véritablement une radio de haine qui
s'est d'ailleurs fait récemment taper
sur les doigts faudra le csa faut bien
vous racontant voilà c'est faux voilà
entre viry voilà ce que dit le nord
c'est faux ce qu'il raconte la personne
jamais fait ça voilà
2002 monsieur mac louis en parlant de
l'entité sioniste est d'ailleurs le
journal le monde qui n'est pas je pense
un suppôt du sionisme qui n'ont pas
d'excusé lourde que le titanic le
journal le monde indique que vous avez à
peu près les mêmes positions que le
ramasse donc monsieur monsieur
mathlouthi nous indique le 9 juin 2002
en parlant d'israël cette présence n'a
aucune légitimité
cette entité l'état d'israël n'a aucun
droit à l'existence le 21 juin 2002
l'état d'israël appelée à disparaître
c'est un fait historique indéniable et
indiscutable l'état d'israël ne peut pas
exister je vous indique que j'ai trouvé
ça dans un livre que je vous recommande
qui s'appelle les territoires perdus de
la république qu'est un livre écrit par
un collectif de profs qui se plaint qui
ne sont pas des suppôts du sionisme et
qui se plaint de la menthe et de la
montée de l'antisémitisme dans les
écoles parce que bien entendu quand les
gamins des banlieues mais un sur les
amas radiometer année vous imaginez
ensuite ceux qui peuvent se dire dans la
cour du préau ensuite en ce qui concerne
la haine propre m'ont dit monsieur et là
je suis désolé je suis dans une émission
de variétés pas du tout thierry la
preuve que non d'accord
sur ce point là j'ai pas envie de rire
parce que le 1er juin 2001 j'étais en
israël et j'étais à 100 mètres du
delphinarium la discothèque où vous avez
eu 20 gamine qui ont été tuées
assassinées par le ramasse dans une
discothèque seize enfants sont morts en
plein soleil par un missile de l'armée
israélienne et je peux avoir autant de
victimes pour vous il plus non je te le
dire on va pas refaire le son clair
que je veux savoir on vous a écouté
spécialisés
mais que vois je tiens à ce formidable
oui je suis maintenant jusqu'au viol
n'avait mais voilà que vous m'avez ctif
effectivement nominalement sur la radio
bien voilà ce qu'odile trois jours ou si
voix la radio a choisi voilà ce qu'odile
le 3 juin la radio méditerranée
effectivement que je cite dans mon livre
il ya une certaine nacira le 3 juin
voilà ce qu'elle dit à la radio de
monsieur mathlouthi le chantre de la
paix oui quand j'ai entendu à la radio
qu'il y avait la tente à tel-aviv ça m'a
fait plaisir
j'appelle les musulmans à agir
la seule solution c'est de passer à
l'action générale il ya un intervenant
qui mène de la désincarnation devrait
pas vous mais là il a été arrêté les
folles années sur les ondes vie c'est
faux
c'est fini avait cessé de poser son vaut
donc prêt à
rester a mis en demeure faut ensuite un
auditeur à se mêler juive de 30 heures
le même jour un auditeur à se mêler
juillet 2e randonnée plus se rendre en
palestine occupée sous peine de pénis de
périr de la même manière que les colons
russe de la discothèque de tel aviv non
la même manière les harmonies aussi bien
des anonymes ont repéré vif
autrement dit les gamines de tel-aviv
sont considérés par la radio libre
années comme des colons russe beau
programme d'écolo il peut raconter ce
qu'elle résultera compter ce qu'il veut
je me retrouve souvent de dire est faux
et archi faux et vous connaissez aussi
bien la loi comme moi sur la
communication si ces propos avaient été
tenus de la façon que cet avocat est en
train de le dire radio méditerranée
serait aujourd'hui fermée ils ont été
tenus et les non feinte reza taper sur
les doigts vous raconter des histoires
réformer le csa n'a rêvé sur les doigts
et vous vous êtes en train de mentir et
vous le dis à mes frères et bien
diffamation mais je n'ai pas le court je
vais même pas répondu sur votre livre
parce que vous êtes un spécialiste de la
désagrégation des dénigrements
qu'ajouter de plus chez rien a ajouté
monsieur mathlouthi n'a même pas le
courage de ses opinions
le courage assume que je dis seule chose
vous les aidez moi cloud vous êtes il
faut que vous sachiez chose qu'on avait
en guadeloupe
ammann a le droit de condamner le
sionisme on a le droit de ne pas être en
accord avec le sionisme on a le droit de
mettre en exergue les crimes commis au
quotidien par cette entité sioniste si
ça vous mais on n'a pas réglé on arrive
à le droit de ces
accords on n'a pas ce soit de louer
un menteur nous avons là mais nous
l'avons condamné à main sur 100
m dans le confort de la
seine-saint-denis de prêts à se tuer
jusqu'au dernier des palestiniens et où
jusqu'au dernier des modèles très
courageux vous êtes de mauvaise foi et
bien si vous êtes tellement vrai courage
et besoin de gardes du corps font
rentrer ici vous avez la console t elle
montrant l très bien renseigné monsieur
tranquille se trouve la fonction sait il
ce groupe composé de vivonne à regret il
se trouve effectivement joué tellement
ravie que vous me disiez il se trouve
qui effectivement avec après l'émission
monsieur vaslui vous sera remis l'année
j'ai reçu des menaces de mort et j'ai
été obligé de porter je rappelle quand
même
une chose importante c'est formidable
hélas hélas en france finira même qu'ils
recherchent pas son désir agacé ça se
passe à d'en face en france en 2002
radio méditerranée agence skg des gens
sont menacés de mort on a relevé des
rafales de vent j'ai aussi une valve en
lui disant la prochaine n'arrivera pas
peur de perdre un ami ne joue et ne
jouez pas les mais jouer mal et
vigoureusement pas à vous mettre
d'accord donc ça je souhaite que nous
mais aussi je souhaite effectivement
légende j'étais avec lesquels je suis
d'accord gm l'a été mais se sont
déversés à tous le s10 et laissez moi
tout seul finir mon émission merci
[Musique]
voilà je me retrouve tout seul aux deux
tiers de l'émission c'est la première
fois que ça m'arrive j'espère que vous
chez vous vous allez pas me laisser
tomber parce que sinon j'ai vraiment
passé la soirée tout seul voilà
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
1h10 tube abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu